foreign
how do I let the fear of losing someone
in the future affect how I live with
them now like I'm scared of losing my
husband it comes from past trauma that
I've had and honestly it's affecting
like how I live now and I'm just tired
of living like that you know
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney's show
what's up what's up
so glad you're joining us
I mean let's be honest it's the greatest
mental health and marriage and parenting
podcast ever ever
and you're here with us
you
thank you for joining us we're really
really grateful if you want to be on the
show give us a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask
um
normally we this is the part where I go
all right let's get right to the phones
or I run my mouth for a while whatever
um something happened the other day and
I just wanted to take a little bit of
family time and be honest so
um
Zach Ford who helps with my social media
if you've listened to this show for more
than 11 seconds you know that I was born
in the wrong Century I don't really
understand how all the internets work
and
um so he takes clips from this show and
cuts them up and edits them and then
puts them up on social media platforms
and he posted one and it was me telling
people hey if you tell your kid that you
make me mad or you make me angry or you
make me frustrated
um
you're you're giving your kid that kid a
burden that they are not strong enough
to carry
and I went on to say in that little
media clip
um it's from this show
that I often have to Circle back to my
son I often have to Circle back to my
daughter and say hey I told you earlier
you're really frustrating me you're
really making me mad you're not you
don't have that kind of power I chose to
be frustrated I chose to be mad and I'm
sorry that I put that burden on you the
number of people who wrote me personally
or who
wrote um in the comment section now I
trust you
because you talked about how you screw
this up you're not just here on this
show talking down at us or talking at us
but you're more talking with us and if
you're willing to admit on this show
that this happens in your home then
um we're willing to listen
and that got me thinking
um
I tell you what the last couple of weeks
on the gang who work on this show
um
it's been a mess everybody's going
through a lot and I'm going through a
lot like
um and so I
it occurred to me that there's a that
maybe by the way we I set the show up
right people call in and they ask hey
what should I do next whether it's a
mental health issue or it's a marriage
issue or I don't know what to do with my
kids
and
um I walk alongside people there's this
idea that once you arrive at a certain
amount of knowledge or life experience
everything's just perfect I think this
works itself out
and that's not true
and in fact
um I think it can be harder because I
should have all the answers to stuff and
then I end up saying something stupid or
I should know how to have the right
conversation with my wife and I don't I
just avoid it because I don't want to
have it I'm just tired or whatever and
so
um
I talked with Kelly this morning I just
wanted to I don't know I'll have a
little the family time and just kind of
be honest for the folks working on the
Dr John deloney show who are here
providing hope and all these answers for
everybody
um we've all been going through it and
so folks back there in the booth
um
what's been going on in y'all's life
I'll start
um I'm Kelly and I'm Kelly yes you're
not an alcoholic um not yet no actually
I don't drink that much thankfully
because this past couple weeks
um you know everybody knows because
you've mentioned it on the show I lost
my mom
um last week and I have a special needs
child who
got an infection in the bone in her foot
and she ended up in the hospital so she
was in the hospital when we found out my
mom died so you know all things at once
um I have a son that's failing two
classes currently in high school and I
like you the other day I let loose on
him about it and then the next day had
to come back and say I screwed that up
I'm really sorry
I'm going to help you instead of you
know yelling at you and you know my
husband has medical issues right now
that's causing some big problems in our
marriage and it's just been a lot one of
those yeah yeah it just uh it kind of
feels like when it rains it pours
so it's been a lot lately and then it
pours it floods then when it floods yeah
I go under and yeah so well that's what
it feels like lately normally my normal
bent is to just you know we've hung out
for a million times in the past couple
years
um is to start like well you know and I
won't do that I'll just say I'm sorry
that sucks and you're my friend and I'm
sorry
that sucks
who else what else is going on back
there uh yeah I'll go uh been a pretty
uh crappy year uh let's see my wife uh
Katie tore her ACL and uh May
uh got fired uh from her job right
before she had surgery oh man and uh
I got hit by an 18-wheeler pretty
recently totaled my car yes uh and then
uh Katie got kovid last week so we had
to miss the Christmas party and
yesterday uh she lost her job again her
new job and uh so we just been going
through it man just horrible horrible
year and we're in that place where it
doesn't feel like there's hope right now
yeah just to be real about it the lights
out yeah I mean we just got our teeth
knocked in and uh you know you just you
just picked all your teeth off the
ground and put them in and then they got
kicked out right I have fully full
dentures right now exactly
ah and I'm not gonna lie they don't fit
well all right they're not great man
yeah well as your friend and as the
leader of my band
I'm sorry man thank you
like to see you walk in every day just
keep putting it in and putting it in and
putting it in even though I know like
behind the scenes things are on fire man
sorry appreciate that
hey Tron hello
uh yeah so it's been quite a year uh
more specifically quite a holiday season
for us
um
and for everybody who doesn't know that
was Ben Hill who runs the board and this
is Sarah who God help her is the editor
the final editor of the show and she
makes sure this show the disaster that
it is in reality looks different and
sounds different when it finally gets
out but
um yeah it's been tough holiday season
huh yeah it's been a big one a week
before Thanksgiving my grandmother my
great-grandmother passed away and we
knew it was coming she was 98 years old
but
um she passed and she was just
everything and wonderful wonderful to me
and definitely showed me what
unconditional love was and I didn't know
what that was until it was with her
um and then three days later my
childhood hero took his own life and it
just kind of rocked everything and it
was a battle of how do I
compartmentalize grieving my grandmother
and Engraving this hero that needed help
um and yeah it's just been kind of nuts
this is holiday season and then with all
of our team going through stuff it's
it's been tough
well I'm I've
I'm
sorry
I hate that
um
yeah you're such a gift to so many
millions of people with the work you do
and I'm I'm sorry thank you well you've
been such a blessing to us too because
the reaction the results of those deaths
resulted in me having panic attacks
about dying too soon and being able to
come to you for help in that and be
honest with you you've been such a gift
to me as well so thank you yeah you were
actually Susan from North Dakota the
other day on the show I'm just kidding
you weren't you weren't
um man anybody else having a rip roaring
time back there
how's your I don't know if it's okay to
ask we can edit this out but how's your
daughter for those who don't know Nate
who runs all the YouTube videos stuff
has was diagnosed with cancer how's she
doing
yeah
um on the cancer front it's been uh good
news actually she was given only a 25
chance of it not coming back and uh so
far as she has been in that odds or it
has not come back and she hasn't had to
go through
um chemo or anything like that so we're
just kind of keeping our fingers crossed
she's still at like about 25 now her
odds have improved to now there's only
about a 25 chance of it coming back so
her odds have continuously gotten better
um but uh yeah it's been really good she
has her last Saint Jude's appointment uh
next month so it's been one little
bright spot of good news uh for us
though it's it's been a hard season of
we have four kids and so
um not with the challenges of her cancer
but also
um having four littles
um and we just we don't have much family
support at all and we are very alone and
my wife and I's lives are very different
she's a stay-at-home mom and so the
disparity of what our lives are we can't
relate to each other much these days and
it's really lonely and isolating yeah um
especially for her being at home that's
really hard and
um has put a lot of strain on just us in
our relationship and it's been a rough
season rough year
thank you for sharing that yeah man
anybody else
yeah for me
um I just I feel like my mental health
has just taken a huge hit this winter
just like I deal with seasonal affective
disorder like we talked in the show a
few episodes back like really bad
especially this time of year and so for
me being in that low and then hearing
all these things happening to my friends
you know it's it's hard for me because I
take that on when I know I shouldn't
um and then going home it's like then I
find I sometimes will take it out on my
husband and I don't mean to so he's
actually been coming with me to my like
therapy sessions lately because I'm like
I don't want to have that happen like I
don't want to bring that on him and so
for us we've kind of been not struggling
too much in the sense of that but just
like making sure that this isn't become
like a forever thing where in these
Seasons where I'm going through this
mental health issues I'm not adding him
into the mix gotcha gotcha
well thank you for sharing that thank
you for joining our team
and holding us all up while we're
falling apart we're trying to get these
shows out
um and I get on a
personal note just
um this past year has been the wildest
year of my professional life
um with a book coming out and
uh all the metrics
it's just I mean it's like a cliche it
is it couldn't be more of a cliche the
metrics like a number one best-selling
book and it sold really well and then
we're
in sold out auditoriums all across the
country doing Live Events and uh
and then all of a sudden you look up and
like Nate just mentioned I have a very
different life than my wife does and she
isn't used to people coming up to us in
airport or checking to see what clothes
she's wearing out at uh you know at the
airport and judging that with their
preconception of who she was and uh and
then I jumped right into writing a new
book and right into so
um yeah there's just a season of some
hard conversations we have to have and
some grieving about this time of our
life was over and this is going to be
the new part of our life and I wouldn't
change it for the world it's been an
amazing ride and we've been able to help
a whole bunch of people and the the
but man it's been it's wreaked havoc at
home
um and not to mention my my whoop strap
here my HRV this morning is just me
being honest was 14 1-4
my I got a message from the whoop strap
do not exercise today
it told me you have to stop or your
body's about to shut you down and I
don't like to stop I left work early
yesterday I just went home and just went
to bed
um and that's not just like because I
don't feel good it's because I've
completely run myself into the ground
and
um I know my kids wear that I know my
wife wears that and I know I spend hour
upon hour preaching to you all not to do
that and here I've turned around I've
done it and so
um here's here's what this wasn't just
for to share in our misery this is just
to let you all know we're people too and
I don't ever want you sitting at home to
think man it must be nice to have my
life so perfect and all together and
everything great
um
because there is no there there's no
place where you can get where somebody
doesn't pass away that you love there's
never going to be a place that you get
when someone you care about doesn't lose
their job or your marriage goes through
a season when you're like I don't know
who you are anymore
um
there's never gonna be a moment when
your kids don't do something and you're
like um
what are you doing
um
that is life
and ultimately if I could pass along one
thing that I appreciate about you guys
is everybody's there for each other and
everybody calls each other and says hey
I need to check in you got a minute to
talk
um I am going to be late tomorrow I'm
not coming in tomorrow I got you and it
all comes back to that one idea that you
gotta have people in your life
not if but when things go sideways you
gotta have people and if you're blessed
to work with people like I am I'm
blessed to work with and call my friends
and my community that's awesome and if
you're not that sucks but you still got
to go find those people and um
I know because you send me your notes
and you write me letters and I talk to
you personally
I know there's a lot of people out there
struggling going through hard stuff I
just want you to know
we're right there with you and you're
not alone
I also believe with all my heart I
wouldn't do a show that there's hope
around every corner
we just gotta lock arms with the people
in our lives and we got to walk forward
sometimes in the dark
sometimes and only they can see
and make sure we're walking towards that
hope
so I love you guys love you all and for
those y'all who are listening I love you
guys too we're all all in this together
have the hard conversation you need to
have
start there we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead
take a deep breath because Churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right let's go to the phones let's
go to Dallas Texas and talk to Sydney
Hey Sydney what's up
hey Dr Delaney can I give you a shout
out first real quick you can do all
things what's up okay well first of all
I'm listening to your on your past
change your future so I'm trying to do
that and uh it's helping so much also
your anxiety book is helping me I'm on
um the myth of anxiety can be cured only
with medication but
um this is really special I purchased
your
questions for humans cards for our
eight-year-old grandson who lives with
us so sometimes he drives us nuts we
don't know what else to do with him and
he's eight Sydney that's what they do
they're just right oh man but I'm a
grandparent I you know so he just
these cards have been life-changing and
we ordered the second set as well
but he's now starting to make up his own
questions you know he did all your first
questions now he's starting the
questions and so you know I've sent them
to other people and what a great idea
well you have been so helpful
and my other shout out is to Dave Ramsey
my husband and I have worked our tails
off we've eaten beans in our eyes and
we're completely debt free way to go
helping everything oh wow you don't owe
anybody anything right nope not at all
and we live in Texas in a big old house
and and it's yours it's all yours no one
can take it no one can take my cars I've
had that happen before
oh you know what an anxious life is huh
well um thank you for picking up the
books and and working through them I'm
currently right in the middle of writing
another one um and it's an expansion on
the refunding anxiety one it's a much
bigger how to build an unanxious life
which I'm excited about
um and it really combines those two
books that you're talking about so I'm
glad you're working your way through
them I here's what's funny about those
cards I got a note from the guy here his
name's Brian he's amazing he's the guy
that runs the products here at Ramsey
Solutions
he said that the printer notified him
that they're out of paper
that they can't keep these things in
stock and one of the cardinal sins of
this building is you'd never run out you
don't run out because people need help
and they finally click I want to buy
this thing and I'm going to start on my
journey to reading a new book so I can
get healthier I want I want to talk to
my kids or my grandkids or I have an
eight-year-old grandson that lives with
me and he's nuts and I want to connect
with him and you finally click and it
says sold out so that's one of the
Cardinal rules and he reached out and
said hey
we ordered a new round and they sold out
within 48 hours and now that we've just
been notified there's no more paper like
we're out of paper so man it's they're
coming they'll be back but
um hey here's what's really exciting
that people are actually using those
cards and their bodies are remembering
here's what it feels like to actually be
engaged with somebody and then I love
your eight-year-old so creative he's
making his own cards that's fantastic
there's nothing magic about these
particular cards make your own that's
fan that's that is awesome and it's also
great that he's got a grandmother who's
willing to sit down and look him in the
eye and get done on his level and play
with him um that's that's a great great
gift to a dysregulated kid man
um so how can I help
well I have six children and
um yeah somebody said it would be fun to
have a big family okay
um
six adult children and four are mine and
two I inherited from my husband
um I was married for 22 years my husband
and I were in full-time Ministry
um he went kind of South and there was a
lot of infidelity and we ended up
divorcing 13 years ago it devastated our
children
um absolutely devastated them in every
way
um they walked away from their faith it
was devastating to our kids
um I met my husband my wonderful Papa
who also does the cards with us with the
eight-year-old grandson
um we met and married
um and he's been great the kids have
accepted him
um we have tried
very hard to make our home The Hub I
mean we have a playroom a nursery a pool
we have a sign up that says feed them
and they will come that was my husband's
idea because he's a deer hunter I didn't
really get what he was talking about
when he said honey I just think we need
to put food out and feed them like I do
the deer and I thought okay I don't know
where you're going with this but okay
so we did that we we we did that
um and for years now
um we've been married for 12 years and
it's just brought our family together
it was beautiful it was crazy good it
was so uh there was so much restoration
awesome
and then
our oldest son was involved in the
incident at work and I won't go into
what happened but he kind of lost his
mind and went from the perfect husband
to um did he cheat on his wife yeah he
did he did but it it was a apples and
trees
yeah I guess so just to stop the sign
that I would have thought would have
done that but that wasn't the husband
you thought would have done that either
right not at all not at all yeah
um so my husband and I were out of town
when this all came you know to the
surface and he uh asked if he could you
know stay with us for a while well we
have the Hub we have the big house and
I'm like of course you know he's very
close to that eight-year-old who I do
the cards with and I was like yeah sure
you know whatever we can do
well long story short his wife are
trying to work things out now which is
great however his wife thinks that we
took his side in this whole thing which
we didn't
um and she is now withholding their
four-year-old daughter from not just us
but the entire family
so I haven't seen this child and uh our
heart
is broken yeah
um so that was one son what is what does
that one son have to say about it
because it's his daughter too
you know he
we wish that he would be he's he's
walking on eggshells
um I get that
um he's he's not reconciling his wife
he's he is uh groveling
in that that isn't the
that's not the basis of a new
relationship everything about their
relationship is over the way it was it's
over
he cheated on his wife
and with a co-worker and so everything's
over and them choosing to stay together
awesome great I'm all about it
but they they're building something
completely new
and if he builds and is involved in
building something completely new and
sits in the corner and sucks his thumb
then what's get what's new is going to
be a world of her own creation it's
going to be created in a vacuum
and it's not going to be conducive to a
long-term relationship
see what I'm saying I absolutely do and
here's the big
ugly sad part of all of this
you can't do anything about it uh
that's heartbreaking it's heartbreaking
you gotta grieve it it is sad I mean you
the one thing you could do is I don't
say confront is a dramatic word I don't
think confrontation but having a direct
conversation with your son
um about
what stories he's allowing his wife to
believe about his mom and dad
about him not taking owner's full
ownership of what happened about
um hey we're not going to start our new
life together that we're creating by
cutting out all of our old family like
whatever and I also don't blame her
quite honestly absolutely she watched
what hurts what his with his biological
dad did she's man she's like I'm I want
nothing to do with his family I'm out
absolutely right and that it's just I
think there's this this
I gotta sit in it I've run up against
something and and I say this half ingest
half not ingest
there's something that a strong
um powerful Texas woman has run up
against it you just simply can't control
and it's it's not in it's not even in
your it's not in the cultural psychology
like you paid your house off man you got
out of debt you got remarried I mean
you've done hard things and you can't do
anything about this one
right
yeah you're right and
it's heartbreaking because it's this is
great feel infiltrated you know other
relationships in the family
well no one gets to see
their little girl nobody
and that's grief
but the more you let that be something
that everybody talks about and
it's like there's a there's like a
poisoned glass on the counter and
everybody knows it's there
but then every time you all get together
somebody picks up that glass and pours a
little bit of it in everyone else's
drink just to make sure everybody feels
miserable
and that's just it it hurts but it
doesn't help anything
and so I can see a family prayer when
you all get together and say hey we
really miss young Susie whatever her
name is we miss her we really wish she's
here we miss her mom we miss her our our
your son
um and we hope that they're doing well
and then any choice to just dwell on it
as a group and can you believe this and
she's not any any choice down that road
it's just a choice to be miserable
and personally I don't need to dwell on
it like I have been
I think I think at some point you got to
write her a letter and tell you love her
and tell her
um though she doesn't see it or feel it
or believe it she'll always be your
daughter
and if she ever needs anything you're
here
and I've done that in text messages text
messages the absolute worst way to
communicate with another human being a
handwritten letter and going back to the
hand it gives her something to hold on
to and go back to and this is not a woe
is me this is not a look what you've
done this is you simply saying I need
you to hear from me
and see my handwriting I love you
you're my daughter you're a part of this
family
if you choose to leave my son I
understand I've been there
and I'll always love you and always care
care for you and I've always got your
back even when it feels like I don't
and that's it
that's it
okay I can do that
um you see you see there's a moment
where y'all can Bond
you've been her
yeah I
foreign
have you talked to her in that way
no because I've always tried to
try my hardest not to talk negatively
about their dad
um there's a difference between talking
like he's a crummy piece of crap
and hey honey
I've had my guts ripped out too
I've know that feeling of sitting on the
edge of the bed and not realizing what
day it is because everything in my world
is upside down
um
has nothing to do with him I mean he
cheated that has to do with her and you
see how there's a there's such a
dramatic difference
I I do and you can tell her if you need
to say ugly things about him I'm I'm
fine to hear it
because I said my fair share about his
dad
well and frankly you know I'm having a
hard time you know wondering what the
heck happened to my son
and I'm having a hard time
respecting him I don't respect him I'm
forgiving him fair what were you
thinking have you have you asked him
no I haven't okay those secrets are
killing you
yeah and these aren't grenades these
aren't you coming after him being I
can't this is you taking your son out to
breakfast and saying hey
like it's been a season
we went through this with your dad
what what happened
because my guess is he didn't like who
he had become he had a young kid he
probably outgoing like his old man or
whatever who knows man he didn't like
who he had become in his new marriage
and somebody else made him feel alive
for a few minutes and he blew the whole
thing up yeah that's exactly what
happened
he had an incident at work and that just
I don't know he fell off the wagon
it's it's it was horrible yeah okay sign
number two
I go through this one go through this
one quick so we're gonna run out of time
here okay
we set up joint accounts for our kids
because I got I started getting anxiety
over giving gifts
we're out of debt we started join the
council we could give them money
uh for Christmas and birthdays awful
terrible terrible awful awful terrible
idea
please tell me why awful terrible idea
um because now we can't see that
granddaughter because because my son
started dipping into my granddaughter's
account
and my husband shut the account down as
he should have
and so now you have a son doing a temper
tantrum
and his wife they are they're acting
like little children
yeah he's she's accusing my husband of
her daughter
here's the deal if he gave her money
he's given her money
right and for him to be like no I'm
taking about that's kind of that's him
being a child
but when you give here's the deal your
kids are grown-ups you do not share
accounts with grown-up kids
especially not these days when you can
venmo money back and forth with somebody
or I can write you a check and put it in
the mail
I'm still old school like that I got a
checkbook in my bag right now like it's
1981. right so like I'm I'm not sharing
accounts number one number two if I want
to give money to my granddaughter for
like college or something I'm gonna open
an account that is an education account
like a 529 I'm going to open an account
and put it there or worse comes to worst
I'm going to open a money market account
like a low interest whatever and I'm
just going to open it myself and keep it
in there I've Got Friends two friends
who when my son and daughter were born
they opened a savings account for them
they did not give that savings account
to me every year on the birthday I get a
text message or a card or something that
says hey we deposited um we put some
money in your kids fund
and my guess is there'll be a couple of
thousand dollars when my kids graduate
college and it will just be a check that
comes in the mail or when they graduate
high school it'll be a check that comes
in the mail it's awesome but I'm not
holding it
and you know why they didn't give it to
me as a gift
like them not giving it to me was a gift
for our relationship
because they never have to wonder like
why is he spinning at that or what's
that for but they took all those
variables out they said hey we've got
some gifts for your kid that we're
putting into an account and we're
hanging on to it until the time is right
and it's their money that's fantastic
so do we write this daughter-in-law and
sign a letter as well how do we we
haven't seen this this one in four
months yeah here's the deal you're not
gonna try to say the right thing so you
can see the granddaughter
that's like saying I need to lose 50
pounds and going on like I'm gonna start
taking math and I'm gonna have like the
lower part of one of my legs removed so
I can lose 50 pounds you could get that
number on the scale but it's going to
come at such an ex like such a wild cost
that it's not going to be worth it
what you want to do is heal your
relationship with your son
kill your daughter-in-law heal your
relationship with your daughter-in-law
right
and so this is I this one sounds more
like a conversation
um that you have in person if they'll
have it if they won't then yeah you
write letters if they have it in person
and a hundred percent of this
conversation is you and your husband
saying we screwed up
okay we put we had joint accounts like
yeah we're 14 years old you're not y'all
are adults
we thought the best way to to we didn't
think about setting up 529 accounts for
the kids we just were thinking about
cash and we put this burden on you guys
as to how we wanted you to and then we
took the money back we screwed it up so
we're starting from scratch
the money that we have for granddaughter
it's in a 529 now and we're going to
continue to fund that thing so the
moment she graduates high school we're
going to have this much money hopefully
for her to go to college
and if you're still having to give your
son cash so that he can live that's a
whole other conversation and problem
yeah
and if you want to buy gifts for your
kids or for your grandkids buy them a
gift and send it to them or buy them a
gift card and mail it to them
okay
yes it makes sense
just don't you're over complicating it
you're overthinking it
and there's something to be said for
starting from scratch and saying I miss
my little boy
there's something to be said by calling
his wife and saying I miss my
daughter-in-law
let's miss you
and I've screwed this whole thing up and
I'm sorry can we meet can we talk
and we're not doing this just we can see
grandkid again we're doing this because
we want to heal these relationships
and the reason I by the way for those
listening the reason I would say one
write a letter one is is
Woman to Woman
hurt woman to hurt woman
I'm identifying in your pain
and when you're entering into somebody
else's pain
there's all kinds of walls and defense
mechanisms built into somebody else's
protecting themselves from getting hurt
again
and so a letter is a great way to give
somebody else the opportunity to read
and on their time their schedule when
they can deal with it
they can read this letter
and they can read it again and they can
read it again
the other one is hey man I blew it with
the money
we're not we're not healing
relationships as much as y'all are
throwing a temper tantrum we screwed
this up let's just we're just gonna
start this thing over and again just
like I said with the first um with your
with your first son
if they say you can never see this
granddaughter again ever ever
they can do that because it's their kid
and it will be heartbreaking it'll be
something that you and your husband have
to grieve deeply
together but it will be the way it is
and you can still send gifts you can
still write letters to that
granddaughter you can still send cards
but you're gonna have to grieve the loss
I'm sorry
my gut tells me that some you being
vulnerable you going first you saying
I'm sorry and here's how we're gonna
make this right
um we'll go a long long way to showing
your kids and their spouses mom and dad
are safe now our mom and stepdad are
safe now we can go back home
the goal is always letting your kids
know they have a place at home here
we'll be right back
all right let's go out to El Dorado
Hills California and talk to Melanie
what's up Melanie
hi Dr John how are you doing good what's
up
good good
um well I'm calling I had a question and
um
just like your input on it so how do I
my question is basically how do I let um
the fear of losing someone in the future
um
um affect how I live with them now like
I'm scared of losing my husband in the
and it comes from past trauma that I've
had and honestly it's affecting like how
I live now and I'm just tired of living
like that you know
and like he's not sick he's not he
doesn't have anything that's like now
um like that's gonna happen but it's
just like this fear that I've had past
losses in my life and I just don't know
I have panic attacks happen every every
so often from different triggers and
um I freak out and sometimes I eat don't
eat for a few weeks I just like lose
weight and and and just freak out so I I
don't know how to how to stop that
affecting and that's definitely taken a
toll on my husband and
um
I just I just want to be better
um
I'm sorry because I've been you
and I've also watched my wife and in
your case your husband
try to
be better on my account when I'm so
anxious that I'm I'm like being married
to a laser right
and it's tough and then my brain spins
out and Spins out and Spins out and
Spins out so here's the hard hard truth
okay
yeah you are going to lose them someday
either you'll pass away or he'll pass
away that will happen at some point in
your life
it's a great um Dr yallum says that
anxiety stemmed from an existential
knowledge that we all have term limits
on this thing we call life
and so the reality is
this has nothing to do with his death
his potential death his this could this
could go at any moment death
um what does he do for a living
uh well right now he works a state job
but he's actually wanting to go into
federal law enforcement so that's
triggered like yeah another of course
yes yeah my mom told me when I was a kid
because of course my dad was a policeman
I want to go be a policeman and then I
want to be an FBI um she sat me down and
said I'm asking you as your mom don't do
that
because I haven't slept in 48 in a 40 in
28 years I'm slept because every time
your dad goes on night shift I don't
sleep and every time right so I get that
totally totally get that
this has to do with you not him
and for a long long time
worrying
has served a protective it's been like
an insulation like an insulator it's
it's been a a an illusion that has kept
you safe so you so you believe
your body's determined that worry helps
out
and what we have to do is be willing to
give up our addiction our habit of
ruminating
we have to give up our addiction and our
habit of worrying we have to give up our
addiction and habit of predicting the
worst possible outcome and then living
in the present as though it's already
here
in lieu of some healthier behaviors and
it's hard because it's going to feel
like you're heading into battle without
a shield for a while
are you interested in that or no
yeah who have you lost
I when I was 14 I lost my my cousin in a
tragic like ocean accident and we
couldn't find his body for a month and
that whole month I had he I had just
recently started bonding with him he was
one of my like closest Cousins and he
was like literally the glue in our in
our family and he was only 21 years old
and and they lost him at Sea and
couldn't find him and at that that time
it when I heard that I was shocked I
remember coming into running into my
room after volleyball practice and
crying and my body was just like I
cannot handle this and I feel like every
time something that like triggers I I
thought once a couple weeks ago I saw an
Instagram post of another woman losing
her husband and crying on Instagram it's
like that triggered my anxiety I deleted
my social media accounts I'm like I
don't want to see that anymore but um so
when's the last time when's the last
time you sat down and wrote that cousin
a letter tell him you miss him
your body's just put a GPS pin in that
hey hey Melanie when you love somebody
they die
and that 14 year old little girl
absorbed all the tension in the house
all the fear all the concern all the
searching all of the late nights all
this getting the news
and now that's your body just is Guided
by that
and yes you said the perfect word it's
scary healing from anxiety because it
feels like it's helping out
feels like you're choosing to go into a
boxing match with only one glove like
with one hand tied behind your back
here's the the reality the reality is
you're going to lose your husband at
some point
the reality is you're going to lose
other people in your life that you love
no matter how tight you grab that
steering wheel that's still gonna happen
and so the goal isn't how do I mitigate
every variable for the rest of my life
and the variables everybody else's life
all around me
question is how do I drive with my hands
on the wheel a lot looser that's
building an unanxious life
and that's you saying I want to heal
how do I how do I do that if I have no
control over the feature no control over
anything how do I live you have control
over two things your thoughts and your
actions that's it that's it
and that's a powerless feeling and it
should be a very empowering feeling
because you spent your whole life trying
to control things that you can't control
it's exhausting right
yeah
and it burns out the people who love you
I would start
by writing my cousin a letter tell him I
miss him
I miss you
here's all the things that have happened
since you've been gone
and now I'm married and you weren't at
the wedding kind of pissed actually
hmm
I got a little kid you would have been
an uncle
or I hope to have a kid one day and
you're gonna be an uncle one day
but at some point you gotta let him go
and your 14 year old self is still
trying to run the show
and then you gotta go see a counselor
for probably the first time
yeah and you're gonna have to learn
your body's gonna have to learn new ways
of responding to anxious moments
right now goes to war
with just a few sessions many many
people are able to
oh here it comes in a smile and they
don't judge their body they're just
curious about it what are you trying to
protect me from now oh
husband's put on his uniform to go to
work
he's been on a bulletproof vest which
means he just is a part of his uniform
he's protecting himself in case someone
tries to shoot him
I love him I love him
yeah
right
I'm way more like if I just look at data
about police officers about Federal
officers I'm way more worried about your
marriage than I am about him getting
killed
yeah
and as an integral part of your marriage
you being whole and well
it's good right
yeah
how does that sound
that sounds awesome I mean he's an
amazing guy we haven't even been married
a year we've only it's 10 months of
course he's been the best year of my
life you know he's awesome yeah and so I
don't ever want to lose them enough and
it could be like any day like I hear
people have like one year into marriage
but it's like that terrifies me and it's
just like but Melanie Melanie it
probably isn't gonna happen
yeah that's the statement that has
guided my life
it could but it probably won't and so
since it could I make sure
I don't leave my house unless without
saying the words to my wife I love you
because I always want the last words to
be that
mm-hmm I make sure I hug my kids and
tell them I love them every single day
of their life before I leave
if I get on an airplane I leave a note
in case the plane crashes because it
could happen and then I go get on the
plane because it probably won't
see what I'm saying
yeah and I'm a little bit nutty you're a
little bit nutty and here we are now we
get to go live our lives right
so you are never going on shift without
look at me in the eye and tell me that
you love me you're not that's just
you're never going to do that and you
are never uh gonna go get groceries
without coming to kiss me on the
forehead
and tell me that I'm pretty whatever
else you need you want him to say
because you never know
and then go to the store because it's
probably not gonna happen
it's probably not gonna happen
but again all of this is about your
body's learned response to uncertainty
to lack of control to Somebody That You
Love passed away and you have to be
willing to teach your body something new
so let's let your cousin go let's let
him rest
let's let him spend his time with the
angels and on
like a loosen your grip on his life
then let's call a counselor call my
friends a better help call local
counselor in your area
and let's be real Direct
I'm an anxious person I've been anxious
for a long time and I'm ready to heal
I'm ready to be whole
you my sister Melanie you're worth it
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back
um today's song of the day
uh Andrew just brought these in
I have a great story about this song So
in college I had a buddy and I don't
have his permission so I don't use his
name but
um he's going through a really rough
breakup and he was heartbroken and he
was in his
um in his room
uh and the lights were off he was just
devastated
and our other roommate our friend Craig
came down the hall
and went into the room
and had a CD in his hand he put it in
the boom box in the dark
turned it up as loud as it would go and
then just blaring down this residence
hall hallway
when the day is long
and the night is rem's everybody Hurts
and now every time I listen to this song
even though it's a heartbreaking song it
makes me laugh with all my gods because
of that great move by Craig
today's song is rem's everybody Hurts
when the day is long and the night the
night is yours alone when you're sure
you've had enough of this life hang on
don't let yourself go because everybody
cries and everybody Hurts sometimes
sometimes everything's wrong and now
it's time to sing along when your day is
night alone if you feel like letting go
if you think you've had too much of this
life hang on
hang on we'll see you soon
[Music]